[Music]
good morning everybody relatives who
lost loved ones to covet have said they
feel sick seeing a photo apparently
showing the prime minister at a garden
gathering during lockdown last year
downey street says it was a staff
meeting there was cheese and wine and
boris johnson's wife carrie and baby
wilf also appear to be photographed sky
news has been unable to independently
confirm the date of the guardian's
exclusive photograph labour has called
for the truth that fresh pressure on
boris johnson comes as scientists call
for tougher restrictions to be brought
in now to stop the spread of omicron
what will the government do
the deputy prime minister dominic raab
with us very shortly first here's emma
birchley
cheese and wine on the lawn of downing
street with the prime minister and his
wife while the country languished in
lockdown
according to the guardian exclusive the
photo was taken in may last year when
everyone else was told to meet only one
other person outdoors
number 10 insists it was a work meeting
and no rules were broken
i feel
quite sick actually i just keep thinking
how much more of me
my family and 160 other thousand
families got to bear
obviously he should go but he's not
going to go there's too many people
supporting him from the inside so
if you're the leader of the country and
you don't set the standard what do you
expect from anybody else i think
everyone can make mistakes i think you
should have broad shoulders and just
admit to stuff
the picture emerged as more calls came
for action to prevent the rapid spread
of omicron with doctors predicting the
nhs will be left brutally exposed by
staff shortages
despite that no decisions were made when
the cobra emergency committee met
yesterday except to provide more funding
for the devolved governments
with so many warnings about what lies
ahead it makes you wonder how much
longer people will be able to go out and
about like this without further
restrictions and the latest coronavirus
figures don't provide any reassurance
with positive cases increasing by more
than 50 percent week on week
and it's not just the nhs under threat
so concerned is the education secretary
about the impact on school staff that
he's made an unashamed call to arms
whether you're recently retired or
trained as a teacher and have moved
profession i urge you to consider
whether you might be able to spare even
a day a week don't let anything get in
the way of coming forward to join the
national mission to protect education
there'll be many parents and pupils who
echo the need to keep schools open
and all the time the government hammers
home the message to get vaccinated as
the best way to prevent further
disruption
but the fact is further restrictions are
becoming ever more likely and a photo
like this may well undermine the desire
to toe the line
emma virtually sky news central london
okay let's take a look now at the latest
covert data for the uk the total number
of confirmed omicron cases has increased
by more than twelve thousand now at
thirty
37
100. ministers say the actual number of
cases is thought to be much higher
seven people have died after contracting
the omicron variant and the number of
those in hospital with the new variant
85.
looking at coronavirus infections as a
whole
almost 83 000 new cases recorded in the
last 24 hours another 45 deaths sadly
have been reported within 28 days of a
positive test and that brings the total
number of deaths in the uk
to 147
2218.
what about those boosters if you've seen
your papers this morning there's wrap
rounds on all the papers asking people
to have their booster
yesterday 904 000 acquiesced receiving
their booster or third vaccine in the
last 24 hours a record for a single day
so far bringing the total number of
those doses to just over 28 million
that's more than half of the adult
population in the uk
meantime premier league bosses will meet
later today for crisis talks about how
to keep football going as covert cases
rise forcing a weekend of postponements
aisha joining us now from uh chelsea
stamford bridge hello to you i think
something like half a dozen games were
cancelled are postponed i should say
over the weekend aisha good morning
morning kay that's right lots of the
fixtures list over the weekend was
absolutely decimated there were ten
games planned only four of these went
ahead
six were postponed uh due to the covert
crisis at the moment these talks will
really be targeting that to decide what
happens the festive fixture is very much
up in the air at the moment
of the games that went ahead uh chelsea
versus uh
wolverhampton wanderers went ahead it's
a match that chelsea requested be
postponed because of the covert outbreak
within their team but that request was
denied chelsea boss thomas tukal said
that the match going ahead put players
at a high health and safety risk
and of the games that didn't go ahead
one was aston villa versus burnley the
decision for it to be postponed came
only two hours before kickoff time which
led to frustration amongst the teams but
also fans who'd already made their way
so up until now the premier league has
said that its intention is for games to
go ahead safely where possible uh and
that postponements are decided on a
case-by-case basis but that again has
been criticized due to the fact that the
criteria does seem uncertain
okay thank you
don't forget talking to the deputy prime
minister in just a few moments time
meantime new lockdown restrictions come
into force across ireland this morning
to try to stop the rising number of
omicron cases until early january pubs
restaurants and other indoor venues must
close at 8 00 pm that includes cinemas
and theaters
indoor venues will be capped at 50
of their capacity or a thousand guests
if fewer outdoor events will also be
capped at fifty percent of their
capacity or five thousand guests if
fewer meanwhile a guest limit of a
hundred will be introduced for weddings
thousands of protesters gathering in
brussels last night to demonstrate
against belgium's new coveted
restrictions the government there has
said all health care workers must be
vaccinated within three months or face
the threat of losing their job
but speaking on american television dr
anthony fauci from the national
institute of infectious diseases said
omicron now posed a serious threat to
global public health
the one thing that's very clear and
there's no doubt about this is his
extraordinary capability of spreading
it's transmissibility capability it is
just you know raging through through the
world really clearly when you travel
there is always a risk of increased
infection that just goes with
respiratory illnesses
but if people need to travel and want to
travel for the obvious family reasons
during this holiday season if you're
vaccinated and you're boosted and you
take care when you go into congregate
settings like airports to make sure you
continually wear your mask you should be
okay
still to come on the breakfast program
for you this morning we'll discuss the
chances of another lockdown because of
the spread of omicron when we speak to
one of the uk's leading microbiologists
after half past seven we'll talk to one
of thousands of people who can't see
their family in france this christmas
because of the latest travel ban
there's been a big increase in rhino
poaching across southern africa we'll
talk to the conservation group save the
rhino soon
but before all of that a grandma in
kentucky says two babies survived a
tornado last weekend by her putting them
in the shelter
of a bathtub clara lotz says she puts
her two grandchildren in the bathtub
with only a blanket pillow
and bible the storm then ripped the tub
out of the ground and tossed it with
them inside according to the grandmother
but it was found in the yard upside down
with the babies underneath who sustained
only minor injuries
in kentucky 75 people have been
confirmed dead after last weekend's
tornadoes
also this morning the tennis star feng
shui has spoken to the media for the
first time and denied accusing a senior
chinese official of sexually assaulting
her joining us now is tom in beijing hi
tom good morning
so she's rowing back on on what was said
previously
morning kay um yeah it looks like that
but actually the language becomes really
important here i mean just to refresh
your memory on what's been a very
twisting tale back in november pong shui
posted on weibo which is a bit like
twitter saying she'd been forced into
sex by john gowley a very very senior
chinese
communist party official now after that
the message was scrubbed off the
internet we didn't hear from pong
for a long time there were calls uh for
her whereabouts to be identified and
then chinese state media started putting
videos out with her and the
international olympic committee said
they'd had a video called her but what
we saw today yesterday rather was that
she was in shanghai
in a very public uh sort of forum and at
that public forum was a reporter from
lianha zaobao which is a singaporean
newspaper chinese language newspaper
that reporter caught up with peng shui
herself and here's what she told her
first and foremost i must emphasize i
have never said or wrote anything about
anyone sexually assaulting me that's a
very important point
on the weibo post that's my personal
issue i know there are many
misunderstandings
there is a crucial difference there when
she talks about sexual assault that
isn't the language she used in her
original post it's a different term in
chinese there's a different
understanding really of what constitutes
sexual assault here but that video i
don't think will reassure anyone who
still has doubts about whether she's
free to operate whether she's free from
coercion it certainly hasn't assuaged
the women's tennis association uh who
put out a statement uh still calling for
an investigation and as it stands they
are not playing matches in china because
of this case we still haven't really
heard from pong shui herself it's all
been third parties we haven't heard from
her voice her weibo where she made that
original post that original accusation
is still censored here in china
okay tom thanks
looking at some of the other stories
making headlines for you this monday
morning more than 200 people are now
reported to have died after a huge
typhoon hit the philippines
super typhoon ray struck last thursday
and saw wind speeds of around 120 miles
an hour rescue workers say the death
toll could rise further as search
operations continue
us open champion
emma radekano has been voted sports
personality of the year 2021. radhikanu
was the first british woman in 44 years
to take a grand slam singles
championship
and the return of the space cowboy a
japanese billionaire and his film
producer have landed back on earth after
spending 12 days at the international
space station the fashion tycoon there
he is yusaku weizer touched down in
kazakhstan in the early hours of this
morning he was the first self-paying
tourist to visit the space station
in more than 10 years
a new experiment is set to see human
muscle cells blasted into space in a bid
to help people live longer healthier
lives the experiment called microage is
set to be launched to the international
space station on tuesday
once in space the cells will be
stimulated to induce contractions in the
muscle tissue and the scientists will
look closely to see what happens
now we've been having a look at some of
the interesting photographs for you in
this morning's newspaper this is what
lady came up with it for you this
morning first mate or primate the sun
has these pictures of a stowaway green
monkeys causing chaos for royal navy
crew after sneaking on board at
bridgetown
in barbados the mum is there and baby's
just clinging on for dear life um this
might look like a gingerbread house
check this out but it's actually lego
built by a lego fan
uh from cambridgeshire actually two of
them using 400 000 pieces 14 hours a day
for a month and it's their 27th festive
build
would you want to go around for
christmas
express shows are some of these
spectacular shots of litchfield
cathedral which has been lit up with
kaleidoscope artwork depicting the
nativity that looks amazing doesn't it
and the guardian has this spread right
in the middle of the paper some very
close-up shots of birds
and a squirrel and finally in the daily
mail a woman of many roles the foreign
secretary now brexit minister liz tross
lose it looking here she comes
rather stately don't you think
definitely definitely not a bid
for the leadership is it at all that
photograph absolutely not
uh don't forget speaking to the deputy
prime minister momentarily meantime the
ill devos singer carlos marion has died
at the age of just 53.
[Music]
in a statement the group said he would
be missed by his friends family and fans
the quartet was created by simon cowell
remember as part of the x factor back in
2004
nearly 20 years ago my goodness
somebody else who will be remembered
very fondly lord richard rogers designed
a host of famous
and perhaps some infamous buildings
around the world amongst his work was
the air traffic control tower at
heathrow airport
perhaps one of his best known projects
was the pompidou center in paris which
is reported have been visited more than
180
million times
since it was opened
lord rogers also designed the london
skyscraper officially called leaden hall
perhaps better known as the
cheese grater it's not in that picture
is it
no but he also did the dome in east
london lord rogers said the building
couldn't have had a worse reception if
you'd worked hard to deliberately upset
everybody
opened uh 31st of december 1999.
quick look at the weather
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
brighter skies developing this week but
it will turn colder then as christmas
approaches the weather is set to turn
more unsettled with an increasing risk
of rain sleet and snow
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
ukrainian troops waiting in trenches on
the russian border have told sky news
they're ready to defend themselves if
russian troops attack
international concerns are mounting over
height and russian military activity
near the ukraine our chief correspondent
stuart ramsey reports in ukraine near
the border with russia
it's over a hundred years since world
war one but the images of the front
lines haven't changed a bit out here
and like the christmases of the great
war the troops on both sides dug into
the trenches are holding out for the new
year
holding out and hoping they'll make it
these are the ukrainian army's trenches
in the east of the country
they snake along a 250 mile demarcation
line
across a narrow no-man's land a
russian-backed separatist militia and
they're equally well dug in
the narrow walkways and tunnels
the near silence all add to an eerie
sense of foreboding
and there are constant reminders that
this is a war
just pass the sign things beware sniper
there's been a ceasefire here since 2015
but it's constantly violated with both
sides accusing the other
but russia's now involved building up
troops even threatening an invasion
the ukrainian soldiers think it's a
bluff
but they say they're ready anyway
[Music]
with heat seeking cameras the soldiers
attempt to monitor the troops and
equipment on the separatist side
their front line is that row of trees
it's barely a hundred meters away
despite all the diplomatic moves
conversations between the united states
and russia
and the increasing evidence to show that
there are more and more russian troops
at least gathering not far away
it doesn't actually make much difference
to these guys
they're sort of stuck in these
world war one style trenches
and they've got to wait and see if if
they're attacked or not
they've literally got no choice
these lines aren't as remote as they
appear however they're actually near
where some people still live
these frontline towns in the industrial
heartlands of eastern ukraine are
tough-looking reminders of the soviet
past
those who couldn't leave are stuck in
the midst of a continuing conflict
the streets are pretty empty a few
cyclists venture out in the mornings
amongst them 13 year old daniel
kacchenko
every day he gets on his bike to go
fishing
he heads to the reservoir that cools a
nearby power station
his uncle taught him to build this net
before he too left because of the wall
what danya catches he sells to local
markets
with the money he feeds the town's
homeless dogs abandoned in the
evacuation
left behind like this little boy and his
mum
the fighting has gone on for
foreign
in truth there are thousands of daniels
all along the demarcation line
caught up in a conflict they can't
escape from
learning to live with a war that hasn't
stopped
for eight christmases in a row
stuart ramsey sky news eastern ukraine
quick look at the papers guardian breaks
the story of the photo appearing to show
the prime minister and members of his
staff failing to socially distance in
the dining street garden in may of 2020
at a time when mixing was heavily
policed a dining street spokesperson has
insisted the gathering was a legitimate
work meeting talk to the deputy prime
minister about that should we
quit look at the mirror cases of omicron
variant spiraling the threat of new
restrictions looming the murrah declares
d-day for christmas with the prime
minister set to have urgent meetings on
today with scientists and his senior
team
let's bring in the deputy prime minister
should we mr rob good morning to you
thank you for joining us
as far as the figures are concerned for
omicron i've heard you say this morning
uh 12 people sadly died 104 in hospital
i wonder if i could just um
peel back a couple more layers on that
12 deaths how many were vaccinated
uh i i'm not sure what we do know is
that a large proportion
of those who are in hospital
are unvaccinated
i don't know the particular breakdown
for omicron but of course it strengthens
this case for people coming forward and
having the booster yeah which is why i
asked you the question um of the 104
that are in hospital how many are on
ventilators again i don't have that
breakdown but
what you're seeing is the the
hospitalization rate at um
104 specifically in relation to
omicron and there's of course a time lag
for the
the figures on the number of fatalities
which is one of the challenges that we
have right now in uh
in assessing the situation we rely very
heavily on the real data coming through
and it will take a little bit more time
to assess this critical issue of
severity of omicron understood the south
african health minister we've been
looking to the south africans to guide
us on omicron given that that's where we
felt that it was uh first discovered um
he said at a press conference that only
1.7 have identified covert 19 cases
admitted to hospital when it comes to
omicron a microbiologist saying that the
brits are overreacting alarmist and
hysterical
well we i wouldn't accept that and
there's two things just to say about
south africa and of course we look to
all the international experience but
first of all um they've got a younger
population and we know that uh that the
virus and the variants can have a worse
impact in terms of the severity on older
populations also south africa had been
hit pretty hard by earlier variants so
when you look at the data including from
abroad it is no s and you look at the
modeling and there's been a big debate
around that over the weekend it's no
substitute for the raw numbers coming in
in the uk which is why um the one thing
we do know is that the the omicron is
doubling um every two or three days and
also that if you get your third jab
you're over 70 likely to be protected
which is why our effort has been on that
and we're making great strides over 50
percent of people have now had their uh
of adults have now had that booster
let's put to one side then what's
happening in south africa let's uh quote
you from last tuesday when you were on
the program with me you said concerns
are overstated and we will have a great
christmas is that still the case i think
we will have a much better christmas
than last year um because of the
vaccination level both the overall
vaccination level but the particularly
the impact of the booster campaign and
we saw on saturday uh just in one day
900 000 people get their booster um and
i do think of course we've uh you've
heard it from the health secretary over
the weekend i'd echo that people will
need to be careful and cautious um but
but i do think that uh again subject to
the data and it's always under a view uh
that that we're in a better position um
to enjoy christmas with loved ones this
year
will we have any more restrictions
between now and christmas day well i
just can't make hard fast guarantees
because as i said we follow i mean you
said we were going to have a great
christmas last week and now you're
saying a good christmas but i can't even
guarantee that there are going to be any
fewer restrictions or more restrictions
well i think because there's two things
first of all we're in a much different
place when a much stronger place because
of the resilience of our
communities because of the high take-up
of the vaccine that's something that has
gone very well not just the overall
vaccine rates but the booster and we're
really uh super charging that through to
the end of this month and through to
christmas so that gives us an extra
layer of resilience and the rules as
they currently are are the best
mitigation strategy that we've got but
of course there is this time lag in the
data we know omicron is spreading fast
we don't yet know the severity and we're
reliant on seeing that data come through
and it comes through day by day yeah and
we have to listen to what the scientists
are saying last week the scientists were
saying that the infections could be as
high as 200 000
per day
before the end of the year and when i
spoke to the health secretary on monday
he was saying 200 000 that day or more
or less we have to that's now been
quietly dropped we have to um change
these figures all the time as you said
depending on the data how bad is it this
monday as opposed to last monday
well so just to say there's the
difference between modeling which relies
on certain assumptions and the hard data
that's coming through which is why as i
said you can't make hard and fast
guarantees um we have to track the data
as it comes through are you which bit of
data are you asking me about for today
i'm asking you about how many infections
you think we've had today or yesterday i
should say rather obviously we don't
know today we've only just started today
not everybody's up as early as us
no no um the latest data shows and i've
got it here because of course it's
relevant and i know people are
interested uh
82 000 latest daily cases
um less than 200 000. doesn't it that's
and and 900 hospitalizations and 45 days
that's overall we talked earlier about
the omicron but look the a lot of the
modelling that is being thrown around is
the worst case scenario which of course
we're duty-bound to consider but we
ultimately come back to this point you
have to test the data in real time
against real cases and see that lag
between spread of cases hospitalizations
and what does it mean for severity in
terms of tragically the number of deaths
yeah modelling that's been thrown around
should we take it with a piece of a
pinch of salt no but we should test it
very carefully and rigorously and that's
what we're doing okay let me ask you
about a question that actually my son
put to me and i didn't know the answer
but you're much cleverer than me so you
will know um if you have
if you've test positive for covid
and then every day you have a lateral
flow test that you register that's
positive until the infection's gone
through your body
every day that that's registered is that
registered as a different case
um
no it shouldn't be because it should
attach to you but the truth is uh
i'd have to look at the uh methodology
that they used but i would have thought
that that should attract to you because
you register it under your name yeah so
it could in theory be you know 10 times
higher than the actual figures so you
but you don't think that's the case
look it's a very good methodological
question as usual um i would want to
just defer to what dhs say about the way
that they uh count but it doesn't seem
right that it doesn't seem right that
that would be uh
accounted for for the obvious reasons
yes we'll have to look at that um
reports suggesting 10 ministers are
questioning the scientific advice are
you one of them we always all of us
question the advice and i don't think
that should be presented in some sort of
tectonic
opposition to the scientists the
scientists will tell you that they are
constantly testing the evidence and the
advice
amongst themselves let alone with
politicians so it's quite right that we
get the balance right the one thing i'd
say is right the way throughout when we
before we went into lockdown when we
went into lockdown i remember looking at
the five tests uh when we were in
lockdown and we were thinking about how
we could come out we always look at the
covert impact the non-covered health
impacts the impacts on the economy jobs
and livelihoods but also the social
impacts as well and that's the paradigm
that we've had throughout this pandemic
and we still do
so you are one of them
no no sorry i fully support the approach
that the government
has taken so far but it's absolutely
right i mean it'd be odd if cabinet and
ministers weren't in the meetings we
have testing the data in the approach
actually that's very healthy
absolutely that's why i was asking you
if you were one of them yeah but what i
don't do is bandy around i mean i
support the approach the prime minister
and the government has taken i think
these are finally balanced schools but i
totally support what we're doing
including what rishi has done and the
treasure have done to support businesses
what i don't do is have those rigorous
discussions uh which rightly take place
in private in the cabinet and then
banding them around because to be honest
with you and i'm not knocking what
you're doing it'll it it leads to
mischievous uh media uh reporting and
actually what you should have in
government is really robust debate and
then discipline when you take decisions
and that's what we're doing
okay um i think there's another cobra
meeting today isn't that the prime
minister wasn't at the one yesterday i
believe he's going to be at the one
today will you be there as well
i'll turn up to any of the meetings to
which i'm invited to have you been
invited
um there's difference between cobra and
covido but allow me i'm going into the
office shortly afterwards um and i'll be
available for any meetings that i'm
needed okay here comes a question about
that photograph that's on the front
pages of the papers um today
at the pm enjoying wine and cheese i
know you're going to say that it was a
business meeting etc etc when was the
last time you took your wife and baby to
a business meeting
well in fairness um i don't live in the
place of work uh where i work so
that number 10 downing street uh and the
garden is used for work uh it was used
uh throughout that week i think the pm
is there seen just after the press
conference he'd done and people folk at
home will remember the daily press
conferences and he'd had meetings
earlier i think with the health
secretary earlier in the day and the
week
and you can see staff there and look um
so it's fundamentally a place of work so
this is not a question of whether you
can't take your baby to work especially
when we're in the middle of a lockdown
and a covered pandemic surely well but
kate as you know number 10 is also the
residence of the prime minister he's got
a very young family and i think if you
begrudge uh the the um his wife coming
down in a break from um the the the
business of the day
i don't think that's right a critic
has she sat down with the baby nursing
the baby there's wine on the table
there's cheese there there's at least 14
15 other people in the garden
and that's because it's a place of work
they're all in suits um
predominantly in uh informal time well
the the the picture i saw had uh people
it's on the screen at the moment have a
look
i think a large number
to be honest with you look the prime
minister is in a suit um he's the
official's there but look the point i'd
make is this
so some of them have taken their jackets
off but the but but kevin so it's only a
business meeting if you've got a suit on
well now you're changing your tune no
i'm asking you i'm asking you i'm trying
to see your point of view then let me
answer let me answer okay you normally
do you're normally fair about these
things this is a place of work but it's
also the residence of the prime minister
and sometimes as in many work situations
particularly given the pressures that
the number 10 team are under they might
have
a drink
after the formal business has ended that
is not anything to do with the social
mixing rules
and it's consistent with the guidance at
the time let me ask you this then why
would somebody take a picture of a
business meeting
well who knows but there's been all
sorts of uh pictures like that flying
around
clearly someone with uh anonymous but i
don't know is the short answer to the
question but if you were in number 11
and you saw people gathering in the
garden you wouldn't think oh that's a
lovely picture it's like a rembrandt
i'll just take a quick photograph of
that i don't think it looks like a
rembrandt no it doesn't it looks like
people gathering when they shouldn't be
and so people at number 11 being a
little bit mischievous are taking a
photograph off it and thinking i'll put
that in my back pocket for when i need
it
i i couldn't possibly comment on
someone's motivation what i can say is
number 10 including the garden is a
place of work and they were there um
having worked can you accept that it
looks a bit dodge
it looks a bit look i certainly take
your point that perception
with the public is very important what i
would say is i'd point to and let people
look at the photo themselves number 10
is a place of work also the prime
minister's home
and they use the garden for work
meetings and that's what you can see
okay would do you anticipate being
called back to parliament before
christmas
i don't anticipate it but um uh the the
pm has been very clear that if there
were changes in the regulations that
would require a decision of parliament
okay i'm always keen to hear what you
have to say deputy prime minister i'm
sorry if you felt that i was talking
over you hopefully i'll see you again
soon i'm sure i won't see you before
christmas have a very lovely peaceful
one thank you with the family
no official word yet on whether the
government will impose new lockdown
restrictions to stop the spread of
omicron joining us is ravi gupta
professor of clinical microbiology and a
member of the government advisory group
on new and emerging respiratory virus
threats hello to you thank you for
joining us on the programme this morning
um how concerned are you about the
increase in numbers and deaths of
omicron this morning that we just heard
about from the deputy prime minister
well i think that it's um it is of
serious concern isn't it we have an
escalating number of cases that really
has reached uh levels that we haven't
seen before in terms of the rate of
increase you know if you really remember
a few weeks ago we were still dominated
by delta now that has changed within a
very short space of time
it's replicated what we've seen in other
countries for example south africa where
there was a very very large and rapid
increase in
viruses that were indicative of omicron
and so the the action that's needed
really is going to be quite significant
because
we're in a situation
quite different from last year but
really it's still um of grave concern
because of course the sheer numbers
that are going to be affected because of
the increased transvisibility of this
virus uh is is going to potentially
overwhelm our health service so so
that's a really critical situation that
we're facing based on what
based on the uh the fact that uh even
even if the virus
even if vaccines protect us in this to a
significant degree uh then
the the increased transmissibility and
penetration of the virus into
communities that we're seeing already um
is uh is of course putting a large
amount of pressure because a very small
fraction of a very large number still it
translates to significant numbers being
uh hospitalized
how damaging is omicron on the
respiratory system as opposed to delta
so that's that's an area that's still
being investigated uh ours and our group
and others are are demonstrating that
omicron has uh properties that uh have
surprised us to some degree
and we we've known uh for for a week or
so now that the virus of course does
escape some degree of the antibodies
that we make after after traditional
vaccination uh with with the original
strain and and uh that was expected from
its mutational of the mutations that we
saw in it but um some experiments that
have been done in in
in in in different groups are suggesting
that the virus has kind of altered the
way it infects cells um
and uh this is again potentially due to
some of the mutations that have occurred
and there may and this is a big caveat
there may be a slightly different
profile for this virus
nonetheless even if it were a little bit
milder um in in a very broad sense the
the sheer numbers of cases would still
translate into some individuals becoming
quite sick so we're not anticipating
that this virus because of these changes
is going to suddenly become harmless i
think that that shouldn't be the
interpretation of the work that we and
others are doing
but what we are saying is that we are
learning about the virus all the time if
we um if we do come to uh some
conclusions about its pathogenicity or
or how severe it is those those
conclusions are likely to come
in the next few weeks and by then really
we need to have made decisions on how
how if we're going to control the spread
of the virus so unfortunately the timing
of the the these um this scientific work
isn't quite quick enough to inform
decision making i don't think why are we
not relying on microbiologists and
scientists in other parts of the world
who are ahead of us when it comes to
omicron and they say that we are being
alarmist and hysterical and overreacting
yes i mean there are dif there are
different viewpoints uh the the
the uh experience of south africa of a
uh a a very steep increase but then sort
of leveling off to some extent in in the
number of cases and
uh hospitalizations that didn't didn't
uh continue in the sort of way that we
had expected could be due to a number of
different factors and so that the the
concern really is that uh the the age
the population structure in south africa
is quite different to the one we have
here we have a far more elderly
population uh and therefore uh and of
course our experience with delta is
slightly different so so there are some
things work that uh that are
are feeding into the decision-making to
say that maybe we uh we uh we should
take a more cautious approach now i'm
sort of in the middle of uh you know my
personal viewpoint is that uh i i'm uh
in the middle of the two sort of views
on this and so i think the restrictions
we've had were um important i think we
could go further um but i'm not
necessarily saying that a full lockdown
would be the uh would it is
is the essential uh policy decision but
of course i'm not the policymaker and
all i do is uh do scientific research
and uh and uh advise accordingly so okay
understood professor i mean let's stick
with south africa and then it's without
question that their population is much
younger than us but also it has much
less uh pickup as far as both uh
vaccinations and the booster is
concerned and and from what you were
saying to start with we have uh greater
protection because of those vaccinations
and boosters so we may have an older
population but we are better protected
from omicron are we not
certainly through vaccination there is a
higher vaccine related
protection in the population overall on
the other hand the delta variant spread
very extensively in
south africa and infected potentially
between 60 and 80 percent of the
population but many most of those were
unvaccinated
that's right so whoever had survived
would have quite quite reasonable uh
levels of immunity to delta and
potentially some cross protection
against other variants of concern and of
course cross-protection against severe
disease so
uh so that's potentially one of the
explanation the the fact is that
explains what happened in south africa
you have to remember that um you know if
a significant number of people
die then you the people that are left
are the ones who potentially um are less
sensitive to severe disease or more
resistance but you're saying if a
significant number of people die we're
trying to get to the bottom of whether
that is likely to be the case or not
projected from what we can see has
happened in south africa and of course
we respect those scientists
significantly don't we which is why they
managed to discover the omicron variant
first of all
yes i agree it is a difficult area and
it it the models do depend on what the
numbers are that go into the models and
so one of my
one of my concerns worries is that we
don't know enough about the the
omniprongs biology we can see that it is
different
but as i said we're not going to have
the information
uh uh to put into those models in time
so so i do agree there is a debate to be
had here and that's it's good that we're
having it but really i i can't uh sort
of take it any further i can say that
south africa does have a different
profile it may be because of some
underlying uh factors due to the
population structure or recent
infections uh
that and and the experience in the uk
may be uh similar or it may be quite
different we are seeing we were seeing
signals certainly of increased
hospitalization certainly in london
where omicron is now becoming more and
more dominant and so that has obviously
compounded some of those fears that we
may be different than south africa
okay uh it's good to talk to you thank
you very much indeed for your expertise
this morning professor thank you much
appreciated thank you
just want to bring you uh some breaking
news um israel apparently banning travel
to the united states over covert 19
omicron concerns that according to
official statement within the last few
moments meantime germany joining the
list of countries imposing tough new
restrictions on all visitors from the uk
we brought you the news last week that
france was effectively closing its
borders to almost all uk travelers
devastating people's christmas travel
plans ewan rollins who was one of those
hoping to celebrate christmas in france
is with us now hello to you thanks for
joining us tell us what's happening hi
there no thank you for having me on um
so i'm a student at the university of
bristol and um i was planning to go home
for christmas um to see my family who
live over there and my extended family
was going to come over as well
sadly that couldn't happen due to the
new restrictions and i'm stuck here in
bristol
tell us about how and where you heard
the news and how you felt about it
um
i initially heard the news uh kind of
well on the news and from my parents um
it was difficult for sure um
there's always the underlying
possibility of not being able to go home
and of the possibility of new covered
restrictions um preventing kind of a
large family gathering
um
so yeah it was very disappointing when i
heard about it but at the same time not
entirely unexpected
um so where does that leave you for
christmas you're at home with a chunky
body on your own
yeah i'm in my student house in bristol
um
and so i'm here alone um
and that's about it i'm
maybe gonna have
a nice meal i made um and that's about
it maybe a zoo from lucky no that's
rubbish um are you um are you free on
christmas morning do you want to come
and talk to us and via zoom on the telly
um i don't know we'll see oh well if you
if you want somebody to chat to we can
definitely have a chat with you i'm
doing the breakfast pro program on
christmas morning so come and chat to us
um
do you appreciate accept why it's had to
be done oh yes of course um
there's kind of been the underlying
tension um
in some sense i wouldn't want to bring
curved back to france
um i love seeing my family and i and i
love seeing them all don't get me wrong
but um
the possibility of bringing cover back
to to my parents and to
um
my extended family is kind of one
that i always had a bit in the back of
my mind um and so for for france to
lock down and to stop you know uk
travelers from coming over is very
reasonable i think
okay well i'm glad that you can see it
from the government's point of view uh
thank you so much for taking the time to
join us and don't forget come and join
us on on christmas morning if you want
to if you get up early enough young man
i know what students are like yeah
that's a large ask
it's good to talk to you thank you thank
you thanks a lot bye-bye
did you know that reducing pollution
outside of school can help stop toxic
air getting trapped in our classrooms
[Music]
monday morning we'll start off grey and
gloomy with fog patches and some spots
of drizzle it'll be chilly under any
cloud breaks in the northwest with a
patchy frost brighter spells will
develop through the day as slightly
cooler conditions spread in from the
east it'll be windy in the far southwest
temperatures will drop slightly in the
east during the afternoon as the cooler
air mass moves in
low levels of air pollution are expected
on monday measuring between 1 and 3 on
the daily air quality index
the air quality report sponsored by
phillips air purifiers
and most spectacular wild animals there
you are is facing a growing threat from
poachers in the last few weeks rangers
in south africa say at least 24 rhinos
have been killed joining us cathy dean
the chief exec of save the rhino
international hi thanks for joining us
on the programme this morning tell us
more
hello kay yes uh
we were hoping that statistics rhino
pitching strats across africa would
continue to drop after last year which
which was a low for for the last decade
but then the news that 24 animals being
killed in the first two weeks of of this
month
was pretty depressing not entirely
unexpected in that previous years there
have been spikes in poaching leading up
to christmas and up to the chinese new
year
what is that i know why but just to
explain to our viewers why that is
so consumers in the in the in east asia
in china and vietnam prize rhino horn
it really is a form of bling if you are
wealthy enough and powerful enough and
have the connections to be able to buy
illegal rhino hornet it demonstrates
status a much lesser use is
these days of rhino horn for traditional
chinese medicine to bring down fevers
it's really all about um showing off how
wealthy you are
okay um
has the pandemic made the situation
worse as far as rhinos are
oh
it's sort of i guess a game of two
halves in one way uh the the travel
restrictions last year and this year
have slowed down the ease of trafficking
rhino horns whether that's in country
for in south africa for example for a
lot of last year there were extensive
roadblocks and so on you had to have
good reason to be moving around you had
to have a permit
um and a lot of
poachers turn to other forms of illegal
activity you know it's a there was a
brief prohibition on on the sale of
alcohol and cigarettes and it was
kind of much quick quicker easier and
less risky for potential poachers to
turn their hand to other crimes and then
of course without international flights
it was um
not as easy for mules to be trafficking
rhino horn across in their luggage
so that was on the positive side of
course on the negative side uh
tourism has been completely destroyed
for the last 18 months um
without the income foot from park entry
fees from from lodges from hotels and so
on and although all the employment that
that brings there have been mass
redundancies and of course if you have
rangers who have not been paid or have
been made unemployed they may well feel
aggrieved and of course they know the
inside routine on security patrols and
so on they are they can be corrupted if
they're if they're unpaid and desperate
to feed their families of course they're
natural targets for the syndicates okay
good to talk to you thanks very much
indeed for highlighting that kathy much
appreciated thank you